I have to turn our attention to uh
grunberg who appears to have gone viral
I say that intentionally she appears to
have gone viral uh giving her thoughts
on how to proceed in the upcoming world
war war is always bad specifically for
the planet if we want to continue uh
fighting battles like environmentally
conscious humans we must make the change
to sustainable tanks and weap
there are so many new Concepts for uh
battery powered fighter jets that can
carry many more um missiles
biodegradable missiles of course
something literally everybody can do to
stop this nonsense is for example block
the roads to Gardens and Farms so the
plants don't get overrun by these heavy
heavy tanks hand grenades very important
if you use hand grenades please use
vegan grenades no animal should have to
give their life for all this Mayhem and
Chaos they have a special sticker on
them you really can't miss them in the
uh grenade Market or wherever you buy
them yeah I cover all of this and More
in my newest book Vegan Wars vegan Wars
this video had me going until the vegan
grenades and then I looked around and
it's pretty well labeled it says AI
humor and even though it says BBC
and it's really good this is a really
good deep fake it's not 100% of the way
there but it's I don't know 94 95% of
the way
there and and this is another issue
where the chattering class is boning
they're they're rending their garments
over the spread of deep fakes I think
deep fakes are great I'm I'm all for the
Deep fakes obviously they could be
abused but the thing I like about the
Deep fakes is they deplete the power of
gotcha moments they deplete the power of
you know you you get a decent political
candidate but then I don't know they
said something unto and they got caught
on camera doing it 20 years ago and so
now that's going to ruin their lives
with with deep fakes now totally
pervasive people are going to question e
even the videos that they're seeing
before their very eyes and so while this
might lead some to a kind of radical
skepticism I think the society's already
at the stage of radical skepticism we
deny objective truth we believe all
sorts of cockamamy things like the
notion that so I'm not I'm not worried
about the spread of skepticism what I
like about the Deep fakes is that it
Tunes Us in more closely to what is
going on right now to to the tangible to
the local to the things with which we
have a direct connection so that we're
not merely being hypnotized by the mass
media which is probably the number one
tool
of of hypnotism of control by the
political Elite I'm all for it bring on
those deep fakes and bring on those
vegan hand grenades now as the political
order Goes Up in Smoke you're probably
going to want some tangible assets
speaking of things you can hold on to
and that's why you want to check out
Birch gold right now text nolles to 9898
98 the G20 or group of 20 is an
international forum for governments and
Central Bank Governors it was
established in response to the financial
crisis of the late 1990s with the aim of
promoting International Financial
stability last month the G20 announced a
plan to impose digital currencies and
digital IDs on their respective
populations Central Bank digital
currencies essentially allow the
government to track every purchase you
make even if you don't follow
International economic policies closely
you should be concerned and you should
consider diversifying at least some of
your assets into physical gold with the
help of Birch gold group call Birch gold
today to preserve your savings in a tax
sheltered retirement account if you have
an IRA or 401K from a previous employer
call Birch gold and they will help you
convert it into an IRA in Gold you won't
pay a penny out of pocket they will
simply convert that 401k that would
otherwise be sitting in a bank someware
into physical gold which can't be
tampered with text Noles kwes to 98 9898
Birch gold will send you a free info kit
on gold if digital currency becomes a
reality you will be glad that you have
something physical to fall back on text
nolles kwes to 98 9898 and claim your
free info kit on gold today folks when
we talk about really valuable
things I've got the top of the list you
can now get the limited edition Michael
nolles pumpkin spice candle here it is
don't wait we sold out once we then
massively ordered as many as we could
it's still pretty tight but we're
producing them as quickly as the little
the little pumpkin patch hands can can
make them order your candles now they
are only available during pumpkin spice
season at dailywire.com shop M oh wow
delish also I've been burning this
candle constantly for a very long time
now and there's still a fair bit of
candle left this is a very well-made
candle artisanal pumpkin spice
candles speaking of political violence
uh there's a troubling survey out which
is from the public religion Research
Institute and Brooking uh Brookings
which shows that one in four Americans
believe political violence is Justified
to save the
country and this headline is going
everywhere they say here we go we're
descending into civil war and violence
and usually it's being blamed on those
Maga right-wing Republican terrorists
who were trying to kill
everybody what does the survey really
say says today about 23% of Americans
just a little under one and four agree
that quote because things have gotten so
far off track true American Patriots may
have to resort to violence in order to
save our country this is up from 15% in
21 in principle that statement is always
true in every state everywhere around
the world for all of
history this is a point I made a while
ago that I got in trouble for making
when it was some crazy Democrat New
Mexico Governor tried to uh suspend
certain laws by saying we're essentially
in a time of Crisis and we have to uh we
have to ignore certain rights and
Liberties uh because we Face an
existential threat and at the time what
got me in trouble was I said what she is
doing is wrong she was suspending some
some part of gun rights in in
Albuquerque or something I said what she
is actually doing practically is wrong
and is not defens but the principle that
she is articulating is a true enough
principle because ultimately if the
political order breaks down then
extraordinary powers necessarily will be
invoked to preserve it and this notion
was defended by the American founding
fathers was defended for goodness sakes
by Thomas Jefferson who was the most
classically liberal-minded of the
prominent founding fathers who wrote the
Declaration of Independence but this is
always true it's just as true as this
principle here if the political order
breaks down there will be political
violence and in fact a a the the
exercise of political violence will be
justified to preserve the order just as
extraordinary itical Powers will be
justified so that the entire political
system doesn't collapse I'm not
recommending this I'm not saying we're
in this time now I'm not encouraging
anybody to take that up I'm not looking
forward to a time when the political
order breaks down and political violence
becomes more
popular don't shoot the messenger I'm
just observing that is necessarily what
will happen throughout all of history
and some people a little bit on the
right but mostly on the left are very
Cavalier about all of that I mean the
left openly promotes political violence
through terrorist groups like antifa and
BLM and in recent weeks I guess Hamas
they're they're all for political
violence targeting
civilians
but that kind of chaos that kind of
Anarchy
will inevitably result in more violence
and the in fact the only way to justify
it would be to to uh use it in order to
preserve the political order but that
gets very dicey very very quickly and
the people who are clamoring for civil
war or armed Insurrection or anything
like that mostly on the left but
occasionally here a little bit on the
right I fear they do not know what they
are signing up
for because Ju Just as we're
sleepwalking toward World War III in
Ukraine and in the Middle East so too we
hear this at home oh yes we're on the
brink of Civil War we need a national
divorce we need we need partition yeah
when has that ever happened
peacefully wouldn't be so Cavalier about
that man man that was a great clip huh
wasn't it I agree make sure that you
ring the bell subscribe to the Michael
NOS YouTube channel we'll see you next
time